hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares it got really quiet in here
so I'm gonna move on before something
kills me oh oh oh okay I thought that
was something bad well I mean everything
in here is something bad but I thought
was gonna be something explicitly like
eviscerating of my bowels bad well okay
that seemed to be a longer trip down
than usual
do you have something cool in store for
me spooky I mean you haven't spoken me
in a while well this looks new
what is that inception or is that the
Mass Effect Reaper noise not sure which
I don't think there's gonna be anything
new there okay
I don't think I want to taste the beef I
really don't care how much percentage of
beef it actually is I would like to know
why I'm suddenly in a beef burger Oh God
someone had a bad time in there
I see a key oh good
you know actually good I'm okay with
that these toilets need cleaning ah
someone get on this I don't have a
reflection sorry bye cool I got a key oh
okay cool cool
wait I was anxious getting a job here at
first but it seems like things are
getting better this chain is really
expanding which is a shock because just
last week I heard this company was going
broke every day more and more people
show up to eat here something still sets
me off about this place in its food
though so I'm going to try not to eat
anything from here I'm gonna go back
hang on because apparently it makes
people bleed off their bomb bombs okay
good I was just wondering if that key
was gonna be for that lock door there or
who's gonna hear something else because
either one was gonna be bad I just
didn't want to be there for the one that
was gonna be even worse okay
today was a weird day the average number
of orders continues to rise it has been
but I don't know about the number of
people today I saw someone used the
drive-thru and order a lot of food for
one person and then about ten minutes
later they were back they ordered the
same exact meals and then they left
again then after another ten minutes
they were back again maybe they're just
delivering food for a party or hotel but
some it worries me for some reason yeah
probably I think you're stuck in
Spooky's House of jump-scares and you're
gonna die over and over and over again
oh boy maybe that's the secret I'm the
same person but I just I go through this
over it oh boy oh boy I get to go in the
fun tube oh I get to squeeze into fun
that guy looks like he had so much fun
with white fun juice all over his face
great okay cool shoes all right can't go
in the exit alrighty then
oh there was a horrible accident today
at least that's what the managers are
calling it one of the other employees
brought in some outside food and got
into a fight with it with a manager the
employee said the burgers here smelled
like sulfur I then watched the manager
grab the kids neck and shove his head
onto the grill the employee got up and
ran out before anyone could do anything
and I'm told that he is fine but that
really shook me today
well yeah you should probably quit if
the managers are throwing people's faces
into hot stoves but who am I to tell you
what to do
cuz I'm having fun in the fun tube of
fun this
all right okay all right cool
Oh oh is that the chain of fun how's it
bringing up the bloody fun beef
doesn't sound like fun hi Megan what do
I know
these people built a whole empire on fun
I'm leaving I fell asleep in my car
today after eating one of those burgers
remember brief flashes of a man or
animal coming toward me and feeling like
some huge lumbering thing was wailing
from deep underground as I continued
eating when I woke up I was fine but I
had feared off the road I don't know if
it's some weird allergic reaction to a
preservative they use or something much
worse but this is my last day okay you
wizened up a little bit whoever the hell
you are god damn this place doesn't seem
fun oh good a key I got two keys now
unless for some reason I use the key
that I had oh oh I made it great where
am I going now okay do I need you can I
can I go out can I go out I'm tempted I
don't want to open it but you know okay
good all right good I answered that
question that's all I wanted to answer
oh come on
okay this is one more lock door hey so
much fun oh okay so is this where the
hundred percent beef was stored more
like 100 percent bull [ __ ] okay exit key
yeah
whatever last lesson oh okay I see oh
this is well gives a gun
get on away oh come on up so close oh
come on now oh oh
cuz I was gonna die huh is he still
after me I don't want to turn around and
look but something stupid inside me says
I should why is the door just gone now
huh gonna make me have an existential
crisis after romero oh shut up oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no okay all
right it's okay so is this where the
100% beef is made cuz hes Walczak
hundred-percent beefy well that was a
little bit of impossible geometry that I
just walked through gray Hey
okay so is this hello hi double are you
doing hey no no okay
with every bite the bone and skin the
temple grown and shook again is dwell is
is dwell in place didn't he did neglect
to the end with that effect good God
Oh No your soul wanders an endless maze
but I didn't want to do that yeah I'm
mad ah yes but I'll be back okay let's
try this again except this time with
less sucking death please okay Uriel yes
please thank you okay no that's wrong
it's on the side I'm an idiot
goddammit I'm gonna kill so long as I
don't go the wrong way again like an
idiot oh hello that painting was a
little bit weird but I didn't have a
chance to look at it properly okay
alright we're fine we're good hmm should
be okay I don't even know if he's still
behind me Oh fluffy purple dude he's
probably still alive
I would imagine judging by the thumping
and the horrible orchestra music oh god
I still keep going away like that you
know like he I don't even know if that's
supposed to be like that that could be
just a bug of the game the music stopped
so I'm assuming I might be good I mean
I'm pretty awesome as it stands but I'm
just wondering is everything a-okay so
long as the devil's not still after me I
think I'm gonna be all right
cool hey
okay once in 750 okay hi
me neither
yeah forgot about that
thank you probably not yay cool thank
you that's actually a good gift oh my
god wait why can't I sprint now wait no
no this is the opposite of what I wanted
damn you damn you now I can't use it
damn you okay so that's level 700 to 750
of Spooky's House of jump-scares I'll
just have to finish this up in another
episode I really hope you're enjoying
this because this game is awesome and I
love it I love it so much but damn II
who spooky I knew it's too good to be
true
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
Julie
Oh